In this era of major movie studios earmarking
their spots on the release schedule years
ahead of time, it isn't too early to start
making box office predictions for 2018.
Among the already dozens of promising projects
slated for release, here are some of the movies
we're projecting to hit big.
Black Panther
Before we finally get to Avengers: Infinity
War, the Marvel Cinematic Universe is going
to make a quick stop in Wakanda, home of everybody's
favorite superpowered feline: the Black Panther.
In the his first standalone film, T'Challa
has returned home after his dad's tragic death
in Captain America: Civil War, and now he's
set to rule his technological wonderland.
Unfortunately, according to the official plot
description, the new king will find himself
facing "a powerful old enemy."
Black Panther prowls into theaters February
16th.
"Let's have some fun."
Tomb Raider
Alicia Vikander is taking the place of Angelina
Jolie, starring as one of the greatest video
game characters of all time: Lara Croft.
In the reboot, Croft is a bike courier inspired
by video messages from her late father to
journey into the jungle and find the mysterious
"Mother of Death," a tomb that might end the
world if opened.
Unfortunately for Croft, she's not the only
one interested in the tomb.
With an Oscar winning actress as the lead,
we're pretty psyched to see the new Lara Croft
raid movie theaters everywhere come March
16th.
Pacific Rim: Uprising
The Pan Pacific Defense Corps is gearing up
for a rematch in Pacific Rim: Uprising.
Sadly, Guillermo del Toro will only be producing
this time, but the science fiction spectacle
is in incredibly capable hands.
The sequel will be directed by Steven S. DeKnight—the
guy in charge of Spartacus and Daredevil—and
the film will star John Boyega from the new
Star Wars trilogy.
If you're psyched for two hours of Kaiju-killing
fun, get ready to cancel the apocalypse on
March 23rd.
Ready Player One
Based on the bestselling novel by Ernest Cline,
Ready Player One looks like the ultimate pop
culture mash-up.
The plot features elements from games like
Overwatch and Street Fighter as well as every
'80s movie imaginable, including Tron, Akira,
and A Nightmare on Elm Street.
And, of course, it's directed by the king
of 1980s cinema himself: Steven Spielberg.
In addition to all the orcs and DeLoreans,
the plot will focus on a young kid named Wade
Watts who escapes his impoverished life by
retreating into the OASIS, the ultimate virtual
reality world.
Ready Player One will race into theaters on
March 20th.
New Mutants
Now that the X-Men movies have exhausted pretty
much every timeline they can leap into and
out of with Logan's dismal glimpse of the
future, it's time for the New Mutants to start
running the school.
New Mutants will likely introduce a bevy of
new talented teens who, as in the comic spinoff
series of the same name, are trained by Charles
Xavier to emerge as a new class of heroes.
It remains to be seen which of the comics'
most fascinating kids will make it into the
new generation of the X-Men film series, but
we'll find out on April 13th when New Mutants
hits theaters.
Super Troopers 2
When Super Troopers came out in 2001, the
cop comedy failed to impress critics, but
over the years, it's morphed into a genuine
cult classic.
Seventeen years and one successful Indiegogo
campaign later, it looks like the members
of Broken Lizard will finally bring their
prankster patrolmen back to the big screen
on April 20th.
According to Entertainment Weekly, the plot
will focus on the original five troopers as
they're "called in to set up a new Highway
Patrol Station in an area at the center of
a border dispute between the U.S. and Canada."
Avengers: Infinity War
In 2008, Tony Stark launched the Marvel Cinematic
Universe when he built a robot suit, beat
up a bunch of terrorists, and boldly declared,
"I am Iron Man."
Since then, moviegoers have been introduced
to a whole host of superheroes, as well as
a collection of mysterious stones that keep
popping up across the universe.
And now, 18 movies later, all our heroes are
going to converge in one epic battle against
the biggest bad guy in the galaxy, a space
titan with the world's deadliest fashion accessory.
Avengers: Infinity War is the ultimate cinematic
crossover — jump into the fray on May 4th.
Solo: A Star Wars Story
Ron Howard's Solo: A Star Wars Story promises
fans the origin story of everyone's favorite
scruffy-looking nerf herder.
Plot details are a little scarce, but we do
know Alden Ehrenreich stars as Han Solo, Donald
Glover will appear as Lando, Woody Harrelson
will star as Han's mentor Beckett, and we'll
get to see Han meet up with Chewbacca and
become a snarky space cowboy.
Rest assured, this space opera will make a
truckload of cash — and rile up the fanbase,
for better or for worse — come May 25th.
Deadpool 2
When Deadpool hit theaters in 2016, it grossed
around $783 million dollars and became the
highest-grossing R-rated movie in cinematic
history.
The sequel has a lot to live up to, but Deadpool
2 looks like a lot of foul-mouthed fun, with
a dynamite cast.
There's also some impressive talent behind
the camera.
After original director Tim Miller left the
project over creative differences with Ryan
Reynolds, he was replaced by David Leitch,
best known for co-directing John Wick.
Deadpool 2 is set to smash through the fourth
wall on June 1st.
"Remember: this is your world, so you get
to make and break the rules here."
Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom
When Jurassic World roared into theaters in
2016, it quickly became the fourth highest-grossing
film of all time, raking in approximately
$1.6 billion dollars.
With that kind of success, we all knew it
was only a matter of time before we went back
to that dino-infested island.
And now, with Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom,
not only will we get to see raptors run amok,
but we'll also watch an abandoned theme park
get blown to smithereens.
This guaranteed blockbuster promises to be
an over-the-top spectacle — catch it June
22nd.
The Purge: The Island
The Purge franchise has been picking off victims
and making political points since 2013, but
have you ever wondered how this night of bloodshed
started?
We'll finally get an answer to that question
with The Purge: The Island, the fourth film
in the series and the very first prequel.
Written by franchise mastermind James DeMonaco,
the newest film will take place before the
Ethan Hawke original.
It's set to hit theaters on July 4th.
Ant-Man and the Wasp
Audiences are in for a marvelous time when
Ant-Man and the Wasp arrives July 6th. Paul
Rudd and Evangeline Lilly will be suiting
up as the namesake heroes, and they'll be
joined by an impressive cast of familiar faces
and newcomers alike.
But most interestingly, Michelle Pfeiffer
is switching sides, abandoning DC and Catwoman
to play Janet Van Dyne, the original Wasp.
In the first Ant-Man, we learned that Janet
was lost inside the quantum realm, but now
it looks like Ant-Man and the Wasp will somehow
rescue her from her decades-long adventure.
The Nun
The Conjuring series is quickly making its
case that horror movie franchises can be extended
universes too.
Following in the success of Annabelle, the
franchise's first spin-off, producers have
tapped actress Bonnie Aarons to reprise her
role as the Demon Nun from The Conjuring 2
in her own spinoff, titled simply The Nun.
Catch it July 13th.
Alita: Battle Angel
Ever since the '90s, James Cameron has wanted
to adapt Gunnm, a popular Japanese manga.
But now that he's preoccupied with the Avatar
sequels, Cameron has drafted Robert Rodriguez
to work on the project.
As a result, we've got Alita: Battle Angel,
a sci-fi adventure starring Rosa Salazar as
a cyborg with amazing martial arts prowess
and controversially large eyes.
Cameron will finally see his passion project
in theaters on July 20th.
Mission: Impossible 6
Christopher McQuarrie returns to helm a sixth
installment to the covert op action-adventure
series, and while details are scant as to
what the actual storyline will be, we know
the film will delve deeper into Ethan Hunt's
backstory.
Cruise trained for a year to prepare for some
truly insane action sequences as Hunt, and
we can't wait until July 27th to see how the
movie star puts his life on the line this
time.
The Predator
Kicking off a new round of interplanetary
big game hunting, The Predator finds writer-director
Shane Black—who made a blink-and-you'll-miss-it
appearance in the 1987 original—making a
long-overdue return to the franchise.
The latest addition to the series works as
kind of a sequel and follows a group of PTSD-stricken
soldiers who band together to kill the spine-crackl
ing alien hunters.
Expect our ragtag heroes to face off against
everyone's favorite skull collector on August
3rd.
The Equalizer 2
On August 3rd, Denzel Washington returns for
The Equalizer 2.
The actor is making history here, starring
in his very first sequel.
There aren't a lot of plot details out there,
but come on, we're going to see Denzel Washington
destroy a bunch of bad guys in incredibly
creative ways.
What more do you need to know?
Venom
Sony's plans for a Spider-Man cinematic universe
seemed to hit the skids when the studio abandoned
its Andrew Garfield-led Amazing Spider-Man
franchise in favor of another reboot, teaming
up with Marvel for joint custody of the character's
film rights and putting Tom Holland in the
web-slinger's duds.
While the Sinister Six movie might still be
dead, Venom is officially back on the schedule:
the alien symbiote anti-hero is now slated
to sling his way into theaters on October
5th with Tom Hardy in the title role.
Halloween
Once again starring Jamie Lee Curtis, the
latest entry in the Halloween franchise will
ignore every film except for the original.
Cult comedy mainstays David Gordon Green and
Danny McBride are behind the sequel, which
is supposedly going to be the last Halloween
movie ever.
But just like Michael Myers, we suspect the
series will eventually come back to life.
Catch the horror on October 19th.
Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of Grindelwald
J.K.
Rowling's Harry Potter spin-off series Fantastic
Beasts and Where to Find Them is on deck for
its second installment on November 16th, following
Newt Scamander and his pals on another adventure
in the world of witchcraft and wizardry.
The sequel will feature a young Albus Dumbledore,
played by Jude Law, who instructs our hero
to chase down and apprehend Gellert Grindelwald,
a villainous wizard guilty of magical crimes
played by Johnny Depp.
The film promises to begin the battle for
the ages between the esteemed professor and
his former bestie-gone-rogue.
Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse
Ever since Miles Morales first appeared back
in 2011, Marvel fans have desperately wanted
to see him get his own Spider-Man movie.
On December 14th Sony plans on releasing Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse, an animated adventure
following the young web-slinger as he fights
crime.
Phil Lord and Chris Miller of The Lego Movie
are credited as executive producers, and Lord
penned the screenplay, so expect to see his
unique brand of humor swinging across the
screen.
"Wait, so how many of us are there?"
Aquaman
The introduction of Arthur "Aquaman" Curry
in Batman versus Superman: Dawn of Justice
was but a taste of what was to come from Jason
Momoa as the trident-wielding hero in Justice
League.
With 2018's Aquaman, he'll embrace his destiny
as the heir to the kingdom of Atlantis.
Director James Wan helms the watery actioner
that will follow Curry's life from boyhood
to kinghood, and Dolph Lundgren will show
up as a powerful Atlantean king.
That means on December 21st, we're getting
a film with both Ivan Drago and Khal Drogo,
which might be way too much muscle for one
movie to handle.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!